and let's start with your guy your
favorite player of all time
including your dad screwball
roger's name
you said that last night on nbc your
favorite player of all time right your
father played in the national football
league and won a super bowl
how and he had he had the highest
completion percentage of any quarterback
in any super bowl including your your
role model aaron rodgers how does your
dad get left out of that conversation
i'm confused you're right you're right
no there's it's like a given right it's
like that i don't even expect people to
like question that of course my father
is my favorite player of all time but oh
he may question it after the way you're
talking about aaron rodriguez he's my
favorite but he ain't as good as aaron
rodgers i'll just tell you that all
right and he knows that anyways he'll
you know he'll tell you some stories but
regardless i mean aaron rodgers yes what
he did again last night no devonte adams
i mean run game spotty at best there he
is dropping balls off the superdome roof
you know into receiver's hands and just
making plays and what a fun game and
really ultimately mike i don't know i
don't know where this game would have
went but it was a mistake by the saints
that swung the the pendulum back into
the packers favor as far as momentum was
concerned and the game was really never
the same after that taysom hill fumble
there was that early fourth quarter
yeah well there was that fourth in short
play by the packers
that i i don't know
how they spotted it on the field
so ridiculously favorable and you know
what this is one of the problems i think
of having a giant logo in the middle of
the field like what what what why why do
we have let's just have the lines
right and the hash marks let's get rid
of the giant logos that would be in the
way of the measuring devices that give
people frames of reference and i'm
getting into a grievance but when you
have this giant fleur-de-lis in the
middle of the field
sometimes it may be hard to line up if
you're the official like well i think
the ball made it to that one little part
where it curves a little bit no let's
have hash marks and lines so they can
see it that's how the human brain works
that's where the ball should be and this
was a situation where it was good that
replay review intervened and came to the
conclusion that the ball was
ridiculously short and you know
oftentimes the absence of that
perspective from hash marks and lines
makes it hard to overturn
a spotting of the ball
via replay review because you don't have
a perspective well in this case it was
so bad he didn't need the perspective it
was so ridiculously short and that's
when it felt like the saints were going
to take over and then came the fumble
and that was that yeah that was that
you're right i mean early on there were
so many momentum swings here and there i
mean it was 13-7
right green bay green bay green bay's up
13-7 drew brees at one point has a third
and 15.
and i'm thinking oh man green bay has
kind of got the saints defense on the
ropes here and green bay is a team
that's built to kind of play in front
right then they can be balanced and play
play action pass and run the ball on
offense but we know about their pass
rush and they're secondary i mean we can
see they're not very good at stopping
their run and doing things like that so
i'm thinking oh man here we go
and he throws the ball to alvin kamara
who you know listen i love my favorite
player ever in aaron rodgers but the
story of the game last night as far as
players was concerned was alvin kamara
and some of the things he did i mean
that was insane that was video game
stuff oh third and 15 let's throw it
three feet hey can you go make 15 guys
miss to get the first down hey it's
second and ten we'll throw the ball
behind the line of scrimmage can you
just go run up 60 yards up the sidelines
break a tackle spin you know outrun
everybody that i mean that was
unbelievable last night it just shows
you mike and it's something that i know
you have talked about when you get paid
players can lay it on the line more
they're not being careful anymore and i
think you're seeing that with alvin
kamara here the first three weeks he's
gotten paid and it's pedaled the metal
like we haven't seen it really uh the
last few years
you know but on the 52-yarder where eric
mccoy got a lot of praise for being out
in front to make a block and he was
sprinting down the field ahead of camaro
i i i had visions of
the patrick mahomes run against the
titans last year where you're just
screaming at the tv will somebody just
go tackle the guy like it's not like
he's superhuman just go tackle him i
just felt and maybe this is a product of
no pre-season
no off-season workouts when when people
get together for their own workouts
they're not working on defense they're
working on offense but i just felt like
there was a lot of half-hearted efforts
in flailing at alvin kamara on that play
and i want to praise him but at the same
time i feel like someone should have
gotten to him and put him on his butt
before he made it to the end zone well i
mean i mean i mean what did i text you
during the game that drove me insane
i apparently the packers didn't pay
attention to the biggest story in sports
last week
drew brees can't throw the ball down the
field so what did the packers do for the
most of the night until the fourth
quarter they defended down the field and
let alvin kamara catch balls at behind
the line of scrimmage two yards
downfield and that to me was one of the
mind-blowing aspects of the night i just
thought mike pettin and that group
they'll they're for sure are gonna make
him throw the ball to somebody besides
alvin kamara they're for sure gonna make
him throw the ball outside the numbers
and down the field they've seen the
games they gotta realize
we gotta see him beat us this way
and that to me was amazing that how many
times alvin kamara did get free or was
one on one with a player that was not in
his caliber of athlete uh so that was an
issue certainly but either way that
taysom hill fumble rogers making big
plays without devonte adams and really
saints mistakes and penalties
were the story of the night and
unfortunately yeah the saints are one of
those teams right now mike i'm just a
little unsure about i came in thinking
they were going to be awesome and i'm
just not sure how good they're gonna be
right now
two quick points before we advance the
conversation our producer matt casey
just texted us a tweet from nextgen
stats it's an nfl account breaking down
that alvin kamara 52-yard touchdown he
never ran faster than
15.28 miles per hour eric mccoy at one
point reached 16.22
miles per hour this is just a guy who
was picking his spots and deliberately
weaving through a defense yeah that that
that
wasn't ready apparently for the
possibility that alvin camaro would be
given the ball in space and told go do
something with it and chris it makes me
wonder
what
what is it that
that the packers were fearing
from that's what i mean
i mean like were they afraid that if
they flooded all the short zones and
took all that away that all of a sudden
drew brees is going to rediscover a
cannon well that that's to me what was
just you know confusing and i think you
were confused too we were texting during
the game like it just it didn't make
sense we've seen nothing
as far as evidence is concerned that the
saints and drew brees can beat you with
downfield passing right now and then
with no michael thomas on the field and
we've seen a no emanuel sanders really
be a part of a consistent flow of the
offense
i just was shocked to the alvin kamara
but here this this sprite chart right
here right rogers breeze i mean this is
this is mind boggling that we're in 2020
and if you look to the left everybody
drew brees didn't throw a pass over 20
yards the whole night
i mean that's amazing it's amazing they
can move the ball that way it's a credit
to breeze and sean payton it really is
but as you see it puts a lot of pressure
on them and they have to execute all the
time
rogers on the other hand not that it's
like flying down the field but you saw
two huge completions right mike and then
you see how many other six attempts that
are past 20 yards so there's the fear of
that in the mind of the second exactly
and that's exactly right go ahead even
though there's just a couple of green
dots way down the field
the the presence of those dots makes the
other dots easier to complete whereas
they're all clustered for breeze it's
amazing how they're all clustered and
pete demelitis points out that brees
came into the game with a 5.2 average
depth of target which was lowest in the
league and last night brees was 4.8
yards lowest for week three
so it makes me wonder what mike patton
the defensive coordinator and company
will really anticipating from drew brees
did they think it was some sort of a
rope-a-dope routine where they
deliberately went out and made it look
like drew brees can't throw the ball
down the field and then they were going
to unleash this surprise on them in the
superdome for week three on sunday night
football and now it makes me wonder what
future teams are gonna do yeah somebody
at some point is gonna sell out
and say we dare you drew to throw the
ball over our heads agreed i think
that's what's going to happen there's no
there's no question that's kind of what
has happened in some of the playoff
games the last few years that's that's
where teams tend to go
and yeah i'm surprised that that did not
happen but as we see last night i mean
hey they could still move the ball
they're still special that way it's just
hard and there's very little room for
error i mean there they are you know one
turnover and it's just like whoa the
whole game was thrown out of whack
because they're so used to
you know executing 12 plays 80 yards
doing all those type of things but the
saints right now you look at really both
sides of the ball and and not that i'm
giving up on them by any stretch of the
imagination no way but
you know play makers on the offensive
side of the ball we know alvin kabara
but without michael thomas there's
nobody else right now and that's an
issue for their football team and i
think you can realistically sit there
and still say that about the defensive
side of their ball as what a defensive
side of the ball as well there's a lot
of good
i don't know if there's anybody that's
great on that defense right now and as
you saw last night you know a few great
players from green bay had their way in
a few plays against a lot of good
players on the saints
let's hear from some of the key members
of the saints organization regarding
their assessment of what happened in
last night's 37-30 loss to green bay
if you're a veteran player in this
league you know that you're not
guaranteed anything from year to year
you got to come out you got to earn it
you know each and every time out and
i think uh obviously based on the
the last two losses um in consecutive
weeks i think you know we have to take a
hard look at you know what we're doing
how we're doing it and we need to be
doing it better you know bottom line
and um
you know be as efficient as we possibly
can create a great sense of urgency
listen i love our team i love the way we
work i love the way we prepare
but there's obviously some things that
need to be corrected so that we can get
back on the winning track
we're one and two right now and uh it's
been a while since we've felt that and
yet three years ago we were owen two
so
you know a little bit of a gut check and
and yet
we're not playing playing well enough
you know let's not fool ourselves um
we're making too many mistakes and and
we're not playing
um
we're not playing disciplined enough on
both sides of the ball and that that's
really just the truth
shaw peyton and drew brees and look they
have started slowly in recent years and
this still felt different because of all
the criticism coming out of the monday
night game right that something's not
right with the saints something's not
right with drew brees something's not
right with the offense they need michael
thomas well but they they probably could
use michael thomas and he may be back
week four against the lions although who
knows with that high ankle sprain how
long it's going to take but they've got
to find a way
to to like they still scored 30 points
yeah right but that that that magic that
we're used to we take for granted that
the saints are just going to roll it up
and roll it up and roll it up and
they're not going to have those momentum
swings they are the momentum swing they
are by virtue of just showing up the
team that you can count on when they
score 30 they win and that's the other
side of this his defense to give up 37
to get shredded by a 36 year old
quarterback now i know plenty of teams
are going to get shredded by aaron
rodgers but you know we had seen the
narrative flip from three years of
horrendous abysmal apocalyptic saints
defense back to competence and now i
think the pendulum is going the other
way with his defense in new orleans
chris well i i mean i agree to a degree
i think you know the first thing is
you're right about the feeling right
like it's just a different feeling where
you always felt like oh it's only a
matter of time here the saints are gonna
roll and they're gonna steamroll this
team like you said agreed right now it's
almost like you feel like oh what are
they gonna hang on here oh
what's gonna happen you know it's just
you're right there's not a there's not
the same feeling about them you know
like we talked about a little earlier i
thought they were this close to being in
big trouble there at one point in the
first half
got got you know got bailed out whatever
that is but
uh it is not the same dominance and i
think we have we've seen mistakes in all
three football games to what sean
payton's saying
the penalties are a big issue with the
new orleans saints football team of
course we know about the fumble let's
not forget they fumbled two other times
i mean blatant fumbles ball rolling on
the ground and the saints were fortunate
to recover their own fumbles so i think
that's a lot of it too the sloppy play
whether it's breeze missing throws we
don't expect interceptions last week
against the raiders right and all that
but even last night coverage of coverage
mistakes on the defensive side of the
ball a ton of penalties on both sides of
the ball as well and that proved to be
the difference in a very tight close
football game the one turnover and 73
yards in difference in penalty yards and
the nfl with two real good teams like
the saints packers that could be all it
takes to get one team to win and the
other one the loss
the kinds of mistakes that will drive
any coach out of his mind but especially
a bill parcells disciple sean payton has
to be beside himself and you're right
there were two other free balls on the
ground and you just get lucky at that
point you just hope that the football
gods let it bounce your way because the
one on the kickoff return early in the
game i mean that could have changed
everything exactly right and and finally
the one happened that did change
everything and really did swing it in
green bay's way and had him up by 10
points late and for green bay let's flip
it around because we need to give them
some praise 37 points scored was their
lowest output of the year which tells me
it's a pretty good year offensively
aaron rodgers
talked after the game about whether or
not defenses are maybe
taking this green bay attack a little
too lightly
this often is just so different you know
i don't other than devonte who obviously
didn't play tonight
i don't think many teams look at us and
think we have you know a number of stars
that they're really worried about
obviously aaron jones is just a talented
guy and you got to try and take him away
but you never know really who's whose
day it's going to be
you know he's right about that aaron
jones had 236 yards from scrimmage in
week two
not nearly as many last night just about
86 but alan lazard stepped up with the
huge night six catches for 146 yards and
a touchdown he looked awesome robert
tonyan with a touchdown reception
mercedes lewis remember him yeah he's
still around he had a touchdown catch i
mean aaron rodgers spreading the ball
around to the open guy that's the way an
offense is supposed to work it's not one
guy who should be the the centerpiece
all the time maybe one guy ends up being
the centerpiece in a given game plan
maybe the matchups dictate that that's
where the ball goes on a given night but
it's about distributing the football to
the open receiver and
right now aaron rodgers is doing that as
well as anyone he definitely is i mean
listen i can't lie i can't lie as we're
sitting there watching last night
i i sat there many times going man it'd
be nice if they had one more receiver
from the draft or somebody from the
draft contributing to this football team
i did i can't jordan love can play
receiver i i just i couldn't help but
because it did it came up a number of
times in my brain last night just going
man i mean they got nobody from the
draft helping their team out right now
so that that bothers me obviously but
rogers
uh is playing phenomenal football we
know that and what and what we talked a
little about last night on football
night in america and i know we talked
about it last week where
i like that we're seeing
11 12 com incompletions a game from
aaron rodgers a little bit what we saw
in that sprite chart i mean they're
aggressive right now and that's what i
really like and i like the fact that
rogers is staying on the number one read
which means he's trusting the offense
lafleur has proven to him that hey my
offense will get guys open just hang in
there i promise he's going to be open
give him a second because i think rogers
was scarred for a few years there with
people not being open regularly
regularly but either way i have problems
with that word i mean that was a
phenomenal game by him and alan lazard
popping up the way he did and matt
lefleur with some gutsy fourth down
calls i know one didn't work out at the
end but man to get the one for the
touchdown uh there was a few plays like
that where i just went that's the kind
of coach or gutsy move you got to have
to win a game on the road in new orleans
like that but roger's phenomenal right
now just big plays and and dangerous
and the packers now 3-0 and there were
questions about how good they really
were because the vikings the lions who
knows now the vikings gave the titans a
good game yesterday the lions beat the
cardinals so maybe those two opponents
aren't the cupcakes that we thought and
to go into new orleans and win even with
750 fans there still is impressive
although the hard count would not have
been working that's amazing it did last
that one sequence was just incredible he
pulled a guy offside twice
he thought he was like it's like when
you're when you're reeling in
and you got a lure on the line and you
feel that first hit and you think you
got the fish you're like oh i missed him
but you roll reel a little bit more and
then he finally bites that's what it was
he finally bit and then throw the ball
to the end zone and i don't know it's
like the defensive factor norris jenkins
thinks it didn't count or something just
went ahead and hit alan lazar to keep
him from catching the football and they
get the ball first and goal on the one
yeah well i mean they're they're
rogers was amazing last night with his
gamesmanship in general i mean we we
heard collinsworth right and mike tariqa
talking about the saints defense all the
things they do it's almost a different
defense every play
it really is that's the one thing you
heard john gruden he said it last week
when he played the new orleans saints as
well you get you get things all over the
place but
it also with that
i think lends to some of the mistakes
that sean payton's talking about that's
the one thing that just again another
guy if i'm going to be there ron
jaworski and i watch the film
that was one of my concerns about them
producer matt casey will tell you i put
in my notes for the match-up this week i
mean at what point is too many defenses
too much you know when you see three or
four mistakes every game
are you doing too much on that side of
the ball and i also think that tends to
cause even the offsides and things like
that right oh wait what defense is this
hole oh wait i got a blitz here i come i
gotta get up the line of scrimmage
oh i mean you're you're always in a
frantic you're always thinking you can
never just play and i do wonder if maybe
they need to reel it back a little uh
from that aspect as well mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports